but we begin at this hour with your
update from South Carolina now everyone
including me and sort of precipitously
declared job ID ins campaign dead that's
because he finished horribly in Iowa
finished horribly in New Hampshire
barely finished second in Nevada and so
the the sort of going wisdom was that he
was gonna collapse in South Carolina as
well well there's some new polling data
out and it's showing that maybe his bet
on that South Carolina firewall may be
he wasn't entirely wrong there are two
new polls out today one is from East
Carolina University and it shows Biden
up eight 31% to 23% for Bernie Sanders
and a second poll from Clemson
University that shows that Biden up 18
percent 18 percent so a blowout for
Biden that follows hot on the heels of a
public policy poll that shows that Biden
is up 15% which means that the new poll
average in South Carolina shows a big
spike for Biden it shows Biden is
according to 538 it shows Biden at 31%
in Sanders at 21% if Biden were to blow
out Sanders in South Carolina in fact
there's a new poll that shows that
Sanders is actually running below Tom
Steyer in South Carolina believe it or
not if Bernie were to finish third in
South Carolina and Biden were to clean
up in South Carolina this radically
rejigger the race in a serious serious
way why well suddenly it appears that
Joe Biden is a living human being and
that is a massive thing because then we
move on to Super Tuesday and once we get
to Super Tuesday remember South Carolina
has a lot of Delegates I got a lot of
Delegates once we get to Super Tuesday
if Biden is cleaning up in the southern
states and Bernie is cleaning up in the
northern states and say California you
could very easily end up with an
incredibly close race so there are two
analyses that are out about this today
that are worth checking into because
maybe this race isn't quite so over as
we were expecting depending on what
happens on so everything comes down to
Saturday okay if Biden doesn't win in
South Carolina the suckers over Sanders
is the nominee if Biden wins and it's
very very close Sanders is still likely
the nominee if Biden wins and just blows
Sanders out if Sanders completely
collapses in South Carolina if he gets
skunked in South Carolina suddenly this
looks like a race because you could end
Super Tuesday with a very close race in
terms of delegate counts and then it is
a two-man race
Sanders and Biden down to the wire with
presumably Bloomberg
in Ewing to pour hundreds of millions of
dollars into anti Sanders ads and all
establishment money moving over to Biden
because Biden really hasn't picked up a
lot of money yet because frankly he's a
corpse so 5:38 has an analysis they're
looking at Super Tuesday so Super
Tuesday there are a bunch of states that
are up for grabs there's California
Texas North Carolina Virginia
Massachusetts Minnesota Colorado
Tennessee Alabama Oklahoma Arkansas Utah
Maine Vermont and American Samoa those
are the states and territories that are
open on Super Tuesday by the way check
out daily wire we're gonna have live
coverage all evening long on Super
Tuesday
Sanders is widely expected to do very
well in California the polls are showing
that right now in Texas Sanders and
Biden are running neck and neck but if
Siena if Biden were to blow out Sanders
in South Carolina that obviously changes
things rather radically in North
Carolina Sanders is running slightly
ahead of Biden but again if Biden does
real well in South Carolina that may
change radically in terms of North
Carolina right now Sanders is expected
to do well in Virginia began that could
change radically Massachusetts Sanders
will win handily walking away Sanders is
expected to compete pretty evenly with
Klobuchar in Minnesota he's expected to
win handily
in Colorado in Tennessee Alabama
Oklahoma you should expect a big Biden
boost if in fact Sanders were to
collapse in South Carolina the same is
true of Arkansas probably true in Utah
probably true in in may be true in
American Samoa but that's like four four
votes in in terms of delegate count 538
says it should be a good night for
Sanders delegate wise just as it should
be in terms of votes we're forecasting
him to take home 587 delegates but
remember that's in the average battle
run and some runs he gets more others
fewer but Biden and Bloomberg are also
forecasted to get 305 and 211 delegates
now this is something to notice
Bloomberg is dropping precipitously in
state polls he is dropping precipitously
in national polling so the flavor of the
week is done
those last two debates have not held
Bloomberg he's looked incredibly weak
Warren has taken out Bloomberg basically
which means maybe that those voters go
back to Biden if Biden shows that he is
not a dead human in South Carolina
Warren buta judge and Klobuchar are far
far behind who to judge nuts a
significant number of delegates only out
of California cloaca chart from
Minnesota and Warren from California
Texas and Massachusetts in the 538 know
but here is the key says nate silver at
538 these numbers could and likely will
change there is still just under a week
before Super Tuesday plenty of time for
the race to shift as we had a debate on
Tuesday night and South Carolina votes
Saturday even small fluctuations in vote
share can greatly affect the number of
delegates each of these candidates gets
that's because in order to be eligible
for any delegates from a state or
district a candidate has to get at least
15 percent of the vote there and many
non Sanders candidates are hovering
right around 15 percent in many states
California is a good example on average
they say we're currently forecasting
Biden to win 14 / 17 percent of the vote
they're warns when 14 Bloomberg's win 13
putas judge to win 10 because California
is worth so many delegates who gets 15%
is super important if the numbers were
right only Biden and Sanders would get a
share of California's 144 statewide
delegates but minor variation could
really scramble the picture so it's a
mess it's a mess and again those polling
numbers of South Carolina out us out
those late-breaking polling numbers out
of South Carolina they look actually
quite strong for Joe Biden going into
the election the last three pulls out of
South Carolina have Biden up averaged
double digits 18 15 and 8 hey end
Biden's got some momentum in South
Carolina james Clyburn was of course
very influential congressman from South
Carolina particularly with the black
community in South Carolina he came out
today gave a big speech about Joe Biden
why he's endorsing Biden here was
Clyburn endorsing Biden I am fearful
but the future this country I'm fearful
for my daughters and their futures and
their children and the children's future
this country is that in the flexion for
it is time for us to restore this
country's dignity respect ok so he
endorses Biden that of course is gonna
help Biden pretty significantly I'm
gonna get to another thread from bill
scher who's a national polling analyst
for Politico and real clear news looking
at some of these scenarios on Super
Tuesday that put Biden in the thick of
it if you were to win South Carolina
everything comes down to South Carolina
so there's a lot of drama here there is
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the reality the
Democrats may be poised to nominate an
actual communist and Bernie Sanders
socialism is on the rise why because
people do not understand that socialism
is bad they don't understand why young
people particularly have no familiarity
with the actual effect of nationalizing
industry they don't have any sort of
principled opposition to it this is why
you need to join with groups like
Freedom Works to fight socialism
well Freedom Works is doing something
pretty clever they are working with
Senator Steve Daines
senator Dane's is proposing a resolution
condemning socialism in America now a
lot of people are saying well that's
just for the press well it's forcing
Democrats to either associate with
socialism or not which gets them on the
record which as we will see when it
comes to Joe Biden is a very good thing
if you'd like to help push this
resolution please text Ben that's my
name it Ben
two four one four nine zero sign their
petition today the folks of freedom oaks
are fighting hard against the
nationalization of Industry and the
destruction of American freedom go check
out my friends of freedom orcs today by
texting my name Ben two four one four
nine zero again that is 4 1 4 9 0 text
my name Ben sign their petition
condemning socialism today and that also
allows them to contact you so that you
know about upcoming things you can do
grassroots efforts to stop the agenda of
the left go check out freedom works
right now condemned socialism text Ben
to 4 1 4 9 0 that's 4 1 4 9 0 okay so as
I say Bill share over at Twitter has a
really fascinating thread in which he
analyzes a few different scenarios for
what happens on Super Tuesday he says
let's take South Carolina two different
scenarios scenario number one Biden wins
40 to 25 over Bernie and that translates
to identical wins in Alabama Arkansas
North Carolina
I'm a Tennessee Texas in Virginia
meaning that he starts to blow Bernie
out in these southern states
Bernie does the reverse in California
Colorado Maine Utah and crushes Vermont
he wins Massachusetts narrowly over
Warren with Biden at 20% Klobuchar over
Bernie by five in Minnesota in that
particular scenario Sanders walks away
with 679 towel against on Super Tuesday
Biden walks with 642 delegates Klobuchar
forty Warren 31 that's the optimistic
scenario for Biden okay second scenario
Biden wins South Carolina 30 20 over
Bernie with Warren at maybe 15 percent
and then there's a similar application
for all the southern states in the
reverse in all the northern states in
that particular scenario you when we
wind up with Sanders at 514 delegates
and Biden at 488 and Warren at like 285
so that that is a that is a sort of
fascinating these are fascinating
scenarios and what they show is that
this race could be very close if
suddenly Biden has this southern surge
then you go past Super Tuesday and this
thing's basically a dead heat it really
is and when you look at the electoral
map from there things don't get any less
complicated right the election calendar
for 2020 is not going to get less
complicated if we get past Super Tuesday
and this thing is basically a dead heat
after that you get Idaho where
presumably Bernie performs pretty well
Michigan where he performs well
Mississippi and Missouri you'd have to
hand to Biden pretty handily North
Dakota probably goes Bernie but
Washington probably goes Bernie but then
you get to Arizona which likely goes
toward Biden Florida which certainly
goes toward Biden Illinois hard to tell
Ohio probably goes Biden Georgia
definitely goes Biden as this thing gets
really dicey really quickly and remember
the entire Democratic establishment at
that point realizing that they have the
possibility of stopping Bernie toss all
their support behind Biden so there is
the very real possibility I mean we're
looking at it right now there is the
very real possibility that if Biden is
able to revive his campaign then he is a
real contender even past Saturday it's a
binary this is this is binary either
Biden wins South Carolina or he's done
if he wins South Carolina big this is a
race if he doesn't win South Carolina
big then this thing is over already
if he does win it's still neck and neck
now one of the things that's been
fascinating is the fact that nobody can
truly attack Bernie effectively one of
the reasons that nobody on the Left can
attack burden
Bernie effectively is because they sort
of agree with Bernie on the ends they
just disagree on the means Joe Biden
made that perfectly clear he actually
suggested that having a Medicare option
right a public option is the fastest way
to universal health care so he basically
says we'll get to Medicare for all
anyway it's just a question of doing it
step-by-step here is Joe Biden
soft-pedaling Bernie's agenda but this
time we're gonna be able to do a Barack
with President Obama I wanted it in the
first place and a public option a
Medicare like public option this is the
fastest way the fastest way to get
coverage for everybody hey so that
really again he's basically saying that
he wants the public option and like
people to judge he believes that
eventually that's gonna morph into the
only option but Biden's big picture is
that you're gonna get all the things
that you want with Bernie except I'm
actually going to do them here is Biden
saying that people can talk revolution
as much as they want but I'm the
practical on-the-ground guy if in fact
Biden does well in South Carolina you
could see a world where Biden does well
in South Carolina emerges from Super
Tuesday and then Obama endorses that
that you can see you really could like
if it comes down to Biden versus Bernie
and then Obama throws in a late
endorsement in favor of Biden because
basically that puts Biden over the top
that's something that is certainly not
implausible here is Biden talking about
why he believes that he is the best
choice instead of Bernie
today people are talking about a
revolution what the country is looking
for a results
what they're looking for is security but
they're looking for his baby with
sustain and maintain their dignity okay
again Joe Biden is he's basically just
defaulting on Bernie candidate well if
anyone default nine Bernie candidate can
walk away with big victory in South
Carolina that changes things rather
radically meanwhile Nancy Pelosi is
beginning to get used to the idea of
Bernie as the nominee according to Jeff
Bennett reporting he says Pelosi tells
reporters that she is comfortable at
Bernie Sanders as a potential nominee
and doesn't think he jeopardized the
House Majority she said I think whoever
our nominee is we will enthusiastically
embrace and we will win the White House
the Senate and the House of course she's
gonna say that of course she's gonna say
by the way Bloomberg has already said
that he is not tossing one dime not one
dime toward Bernie Sanders if Bernie
wins the nomination
he's not going to spend one one narrow
dime on Bernie so the Democrats are
taking that into account too they're
figuring okay well fit so if this turns
into a two-person race watch for the
money to come in to play and honestly if
Biden wins South Carolina walking away
Bloomberg's smart move would be to pull
out but continue to run the ads it be to
endorse Biden and then continue to run
the ads against Bernie that would be the
way to guarantee that Bernie doesn't get
the nomination if that's truly what what
Bloomberg cares about but ego plays so
much into this stuff guys I mean
Bloomberg probably won't pull out even
if it's obvious that he's going nowhere
simply because he's got his ego and his
cash invested in this thing